GQ Magazine says there's a post-pandemic tattoo boom.
So today, we've got a mom joining us.
She recently became an empty nester to Jonathan and Thomas
and she wants to show her kids a little love
with some body art.
I actually have my daughter's names tattooed on my wrist
but I felt like it wasn't enough.
I've been wanting to scratch that itch.
And so guess what, I'm joining Christine today.
And we're both getting tattoos right here, right now.
And today will be a day that we will never forget.
(Drew laughing)
And the coolest thing is we are also going to hang out
with none other
than the very first woman
to win "Ink Master",
it's Ryan Ashley.
(audience clapping and cheering)
So Christine and I will be your loyal, humble subjects
today, Ryan.
Christine, what are you getting today
and what's the significance of it?
Drew, I'm so excited to be here first all.
And I'm getting a sun and moon tattoo.
I'm recently divorced,
so I'm
up for new beginnings.
And I've been talking about it forever,
and when the pandemic hit, I wasn't able to do it.
I'm so excited to be a part of this moment with you.
I am so excited to be a part of this moment
with everyone here.
It's incredible.
(audience clapping)
I hope it's okay that I cut in on your dance with Ryan.
I thought we could create a triangle of a day
that all of us will never forget.
I mean, Ryan, you are, when I talk about you,
people freak out because you are such a superstar
in the tattoo world.
You lead seminars.
You are the first female to win "Ink Masters."
You have spinoff shows.
I mean, you're the one.
Oh my gosh.
That is, it's crazy hearing that
because I also became a new mom very recently.
And I will say, it is the hardest job I've had so far.
So this is an incredible experience.
I am so excited for you, Christine.
And excited to be here.
And I think it's gonna be something
really, really incredible.
(audience clapping and cheering)
A Mother's Day that none of us will ever forget.
And we'll check in throughout the show.
Christine, you'll be getting your tattoo.
We're gonna do ours at the News Desk,
which I thought was really fun.
(Ryan laughing)
So let's get started.
How's it going, ladies?
I'm gonna have to say,
usually when people sit this well for their first tattoo,
they don't stick with one.
I'm just gonna put that out there.
She's doing good.
Whoa!
I'm so excited.
(audience clapping)
Interesting, interesting.
And Christine, can you describe the feeling
of your very first tattoo?
It's a piece of cake.
Drew, you're getting a tattoo on television.
I am.
I'm so excited for you.
I can't wait to see what you're getting.
I am so excited, I came up with this phrase,
and I've been saying it to myself for the last five years.
What is it?
It's home is where we are.
Aww.
You know, if you're somewhere on vacation,
or you're in a rental, or you're in transition,
or you have to move from one state to the next.
If you're together, that's where home is.
I could not love that more.
(all clapping)
That's amazing.
Okay, Christine, are you ready to see
your very first tattoo?
I am, I'm so excited.
Oh my gosh, let's see it.
Oh my gosh.
(audience clapping)
Christine.
I love it.
Drew, I love it.
It is gorgeous.
I'm so honored.
It is absolutely beautiful in way more than I ever expected.
And it means so much to have my children's initials on
as art and I'm so grateful.
Thank you so very much.
Oh, Christine.
It's absolutely beautiful.
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh.
This is, been a dream.
It's a dream come true for me.
Oh my gosh.
It is a dream come true for me too.
Okay, I'll show mine as well.
I'll show you mine if you show me yours.
All right, I'm ready for a big reveal.
Let's see.
There it is.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Home is where we are.
And wherever life takes you,
if you are lucky enough
to be alongside of people you love,
then to me, that became the definition of home.
(audience clapping)
Nice.
So thank you
for putting this most important life lesson
on my arm permanently.
No, it's my honor and my pleasure,
and I couldn't be happier about the whole experience.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
And to my daughters,
if you ever get to see this episode,
you are my home and I love you more than anything.
You are the reason I understand my whole life
because of you.
So thank you.
You are my home.
(audience clapping)
Bye.
(bright upbeat theme music)